hello friends it's still October and so
these are all still kind of scary in a
small town in the Czech Republic there
is a church that makes you realize that
underneath all that skin and blood and
muscle you've been carrying around
you're really just a chandelier I'm a
fan of bone buildings also known as osso
Aries these are places where bones have
been collected and built and arranged
into fantastical displays there is
Edinburgh
there is San Bernadino there is the
Capuchin crypt in Rome in hallstatt
Austria there's an incredible example of
a charnel house where the skulls have
all been painted with beautiful
intricate designs but among ossuary
there is one that stands out it is both
the most popular ossuary and probably
the most incredible example of bone art
ever created I'm talking about Sedlec
ossuary also known as the bone church
like most other ossuary Sedlec was born
out of necessity so in the 1200 the
abbot of the Sedlec monastery was sent
to the Holy Land sent to Jerusalem by
the king of bohemia and he brought
something back with him a little handful
of holy soil and he sprinkled this
across the graveyard
in the monastery it basically meant that
you could not be buried under a more
divine soil anywhere except for the holy
land itself the problem of course is
when you've got the hottest cemetery in
bohemia you run out of space pretty
quick so they had a solution to this
they just dug everyone up made an
ossuary and started moving the bones
from the soil into the basement where
you put all the stuff that you kind of
need but you know don't care that much
about there was a secondary element to
this which is that by looking at the
bones by contemplating the bones the
monks of Sedlec were able to experience
a kind of a mental more-- a sense of
Ritu shalt die so well half blind monks
were stacking bones in the basement for
hundreds of years so the cassowary
didn't become the bone church until 1870
when a rich noble family bought the
church and hired a local wood carver
named Francis Scheck rint to arrange the
bones artfully this was the ultimate
home decorating challenge and with your
only choice of decor is bone he actually
had to take all the bones and bleach
them to get them into a kind of a
uniform color set the Casa is not that
big but within that small space are the
remains of someone between 40,000 and
70,000 people besides of making four
huge pyramids of just tightly stack
bones and skulls in the center of the
room is a huge bone chandelier said to
contain at least one of every bone in
the human body plus a bunch more
stringing out from there are little
Garland's of skulls
it is perhaps the most artistic use of
skeletons that that exists in the world
but there's a problem
the church is slowly collapsing in on
itself unfortunately to get at the
structure and Shore it up the bones are
gonna need to be removed one at a time
and then put back together and they
haven't really been touched since the
1870s in fact no one's even sure how
those bone pyramids are being held
together so well this is an enormous and
insane project and I would really like
to be there when they start doing this
the only other option is to let the bone
church collapse in on itself chandelier
and all and I would rather not be there
when that happens yeah bones I'm being
buried in bones subscribe here and watch
more videos here and as a challenge the
first person to guess what animal these
bones are from and put it in the
comments you get to call 101 der episode
I will make it in November I am I'm
yours to command
but animal if you find that sub LoCascio
area is a little too touristy for your
taste
you've got other choices 20 miles away
there's an ossuary and Melnick that is
basically totally UNMISS it in Poland
there is an incredible small ossuary
that may have been what inspired
Frantisek rint in his styling of Sedlec
ossuary and finally in czech republic
there is beer know which is the largest
ossuary outside of the parisian
catacombs